ELIJAH BLAKE: All right.
So we're going to do a quick
demo on redux integration
with our Expo app.
So catching up
from last lecture,
we had this, a redux form
powered form inputs here,
to submit registration
data for a user.
And again on the code, we had--
in our index.jsx,
we used the redux
react hook form to use
form and set up this form.
And that's just for
validation to make
sure that we can't submit
nonsense data with our form
input here.
So once we get this
with react hook form,
we get all of the data.
And we have it available in
the onSubmit function, which
we're just console.login
at the moment.
But we will want
to take this data
and then put it
somewhere so that we
can use it in our projects.
Eventually, that is going to be
pushing it to our Django server
so that the data gets
into the database.
But for now, we are
just going to store it
in our front ends redux store.
So let's go ahead
and get that set up.
So let's copy our
component here,
which has all the information
about what form inputs we have,
what types they
submit, et cetera.
And let's go over
here to our GPT.
Or you could use in
line one that you
have set up in your editor.
But I'm just going to prompt.
I have this form component.
I want to add the form
data to a redux slice.
And when you're
prompting, if you
want to do it the same
way that we are in class,
do use this terminology,
redux slice.
The redux is a way to manage
global state in our app.
And there are other solutions
or products for it as well.
Redux is the one that I
am the most familiar with.
And it's been around
for a long time.
So it's pretty mature as far
as global state management
solutions go.
So it's got just
about everything.
And then slice is a specific
implementation of redux.
There are lots of different
ways to write redux reducers.
Slice boils it down to one
file for a certain data type,
instead of having
to break it out
into actions and reducers
and side effects and all
those things.
It's all done right here
in one file for you.
So yeah.
Whatever you do,
remember if you want
to do it the same way
we're doing it in class,
use a redux slice.
So we're going to add the
form data to redux slice.
And let's just say I don't
have redux in my a project yet.
But I do believe-- let's
double check package.json.
Do we have-- no redux?
So that way it'll know
it needs to help us
get everything installed too.
Let's just go ahead
and start with that.
Oh, I didn't include the code.
There we go.
Let's try that.
Now also we're talking about--
all right.
So we are going to need to
install some dependencies,
which is @redux/toolkit.
This is the-- so react
redux is the core bit.
We need to use redux
in our Expo/React app.
If you were doing just react
JS for web, even without Expo,
this stuff would
all be the same.
In fact, regardless
of whether you're
doing mobile, or web, or
Expo, or just normal web react
with any build solution
or bundler solution,
redux code is the exact
same across all situations.
So it's kind of nice that way.
Let's go ahead and
open our terminal.
Going to kill the metro server.
NPM install.
Yeah.
Go ahead and let that run while
we keep reading through here.
Set up your redux store.
So this is the code that
we'll need to set up,
just the basic store.
So I'm going to go
ahead and copy that.
And then in my project,
inside of my Expo app,
I'm going to make a new folder.
I'm going to call it state.
Let's see.
And where did they put it?
So they're just saying, for
example, call it store.js.
I'm going to put it inside
of a folder called state.
This is going to be for managing
all global state solutions.
And then inside there, I'm going
to add a store.js file and put
that code in there.
They put it in slash
redux store JS.
I'm going to call it state.
Then create a redux slice.
This is the basic data we need.
And they're using
a normal reducer.
That's great.
And then they're
calling it user slice.
Inside of state, I'm going to
add a new file user slice.js.
And the names here
don't matter a ton
as long as you get your
import paths matching.
So let's see from here.
Yeah, it's expecting user
slice to be dot slash.
We're going to import our user
reducer from dot slash user
slice.
Dot slash means in the same
folder that this file is.
So store.js is inside the
same file as our user slice.js
If user slice was
one folder up, we
would need a dot dot slash
if user slice was in--
let's say we had another
folder here called slices
and our user slice was in there.
We would need to
dot slash slices
and then grab it in there.
Oops, leave the
last slash there.
And I'm not going to have a
slices folder at least for now.
So we're importing our
slice and adding it
where we configure store.
Then we have a reducer or user
reducer is added to this object.
So then let's just look at this
code here inside of our slice
itself.
Make sure we understand
what's going on here.
So every reducer or every
slice for our reducer
will have three things.
Later it'll have a fourth thing.
But it needs to have a
name that's required.
It needs to have some
sort of initial state.
In this case, it's
called formdata,
which is just an empty object
which we will be filling later.
And actually, I
wonder if it should
be a list because our
form lets users-- it lets
us put multiple users in here.
We could do one.
Then when we submit, we
could add another one.
We may want to ask our
friendly neighborhood
GPT to modify this
for us so that we
can keep track of multiple users
in here instead of just one.
So anyway, we have our
name, our initial state,
which is defined here.
We're just saying we have form
data, which is an empty object.
And then in our reducers,
we have this add form data.
And this is an action add form
data action, which we modify.
In here, we have the
state form data, which
matches this piece of state.
Then we're just passing
our action.payload,
whatever payload
gets passed when
we call this reducer action.
And then it'll show
us how to use it.
I'm sure wrap your
app with a provider.
Don't forget this step.
Otherwise, it will just give you
read errors all over the place.
Let's go ahead and open our--
it's saying app.js.
I didn't tell it that.
I'm using Expo, did I?
No.
So I didn't tell it that we're
using expo so it didn't know.
So here it's talking
about app.js.
If you're doing a regular react
app, this is what you will see.
You would have an app.js file.
In our case, Expo's
structures slightly different.
Instead of looking for
an app.js file that
our app initiates, that we are
going to look at the app folder.
And then inside of our app
folder, there's a _layout.jsx.
And in there is
where we're going
to want to set up our provider.
But the structure
here is the same.
We're going to pass.
Provider actually let's
get our imports in first.
So let's import
provider from redux.
And then we need to ask
a store provider boom
and they put the closing
tag in there for us.
[INAUDIBLE] And I'll indent
those so it's all pretty.
And then it has this store
thing that it expects.
Well, where do we get that?
They're importing store from
slash redux slash store.
I'm going to import it
slightly differently because I
didn't put it in the same
folder name that they did.
But I am still going
to import store from.
And then I called it state.
I need dot slash and dot
dot slash states/store.
And it is.
If you look over
here, we have state.
And then inside of state,
we have state store.js.
And our import paths when it's a
JavaScript file or a TypeScript
file, we do not need the
dot JS or dot TS extension.
And again, we're inside
of our app folder.
And state is a different folder.
So I'm going up one level
to get out of the app folder
and then into state store.
So just making sure we get
the import paths right.
Sometimes this is
also set up so that we
can start if you're
several layers deep
and you don't want to count
how many folders up you
need to navigate out to get
into another folder structure.
I think by default Expo
accepts dynamic imports.
Yeah.
So this ampersand can just say
from the root of my project.
So wherever your
package.json lives.
So from that same
location, go start--
it's basically saying
go start from the root
and then go in to
the state folder
and then the store
file inside of there.
So either kind of import path
will work in your expo project
by default.
And then dispatch the
action from your component.
So it just regenerated
our component again.
And then on Submit, this
function has changed.
There's still console
logging our form data for us.
How nice of them?
But before they do
any of that, they're
are dispatching add
form data, which
is if we look at our slice,
what this guy is called.
That's our add form data action.
So it's dispatching that action
with the data from our form.
So we can go ahead
and grab that.
Let's open our index.jsx
copy in the updated code.
And we'll see that
onSubmit has been changed
to fire off that dispatch.
And speaking of
dispatch, anytime you
want to update redux,
your redux store state,
it will have to be done
through this dispatch hook.
So you're going to
import use dispatch.
And again, anything with
that starts with the word use
by convention, that means
this is a redux hook.
All that means is it's
a special function that
keeps track of and responds to
user updates in your react uI.
So we're going to import use
dispatch from react redux
and we're going to import
the action from our slice.
Oh, look at that.
They gave us a
little reminder here.
Thanks.
Yeah, we will update
that import path.
And actually, it's dot/state.
This isn't going to work because
we're inside of the app folder.
We would need to go up out
of the app folder first
and then into state.
Or we could can just
do that and then
we don't need to know how
many times we need to go.
So anyway, we import use
dispatch from react redux.
And then we need to set
up our dispatch object.
So that's why we've got-- we're
calling use dispatch here.
And we're grabbing
this dispatch object.
Then we get to use that
and pass it our action.
And we pass that
action the data.
So we're passing
data as an argument
to the add form data function,
which is a redux action.
And then we're passing that
whole function and its argument
as an argument to dispatch.
So that will trigger the
redux action to dispatch
and any data updates will be
tracked with our redux store.
Then let's see if it's got
any other notes for us.
Yeah, that should be it.
OK.
So with our new slice, our store
setup, and our provider wrapping
our entire app, because our app
starts at this stack object,
we should have our entire
app has access to this store
and the user data
inside of this slice.
So we can go ahead and try that.
We'll have to-- excuse me.
We spun down our server.
So let's NPM start our
metro server again.
Hit W to open up the
web and close that one.
Have that.
And then just so we
can see this in action.
Inside of our user
slice, I'm going
to console.log user data slice.
And I'm going to give
it action.payload.
Should see that data coming
through in our slice.
Let's give it a shot.
My name's Elijah Blake.
And I give it 555 number because
that area code doesn't exist.
And yeah, sure.
I mean, I like red.
Let's open up our DevTools, F12.
We've got the console open.
So when I hit Submit, we should
see our logs come through.
There we go.
We've got two of them.
Whoops, first one down
here is use data slice.
That looks familiar.
That's what we put
in our redux slice.
And we've got our
email, favorite color,
blah, blah, blah.
All that data came through.
This one down here
was just the data
and that one was inside
of our index.jsx onSubmit,
if I remember.
Yap.
Form data.
So we're seeing the data
in our Submit function,
in our index.jsx.
And we're dispatching.
And we dispatched our
action before that,
which is why we saw this
slice log come through first.
Because inside of onSubmit,
we dispatch that action first.
It triggered this action
function, which logged this guy
and then after that, it kept
executing in the onSubmit
and lock to this one next.
And I didn't see
the alert file fire.
But is it-- no.
Yeah, I don't see it.
Maybe I have those blocks.
Brave does block things
like that sometimes.
Either way, we don't need it.
And then that resets
the form for us.
Yeah, cleared all the
form entries on Submit,
which is nice.
So we can import or input
fresh data afterwards.
Yeah, that's it.
That's all it takes
to set up the form,
at least so we can submit
our data to our redux store.
Now, what about
reading that data?
So we could import
data from the store
and display it here
in our index.jsx.
But the power and the
point of using redux
is so that we can share
data across multiple pages
or components.
So let's go ahead and
set up a new component.
And again, the way
we do that in Expo,
if you're using
Expo router, is just
to add a new file in
our app directory.
So let's just call this
one display user data.jsx.
I'm going to copy that name.
And then now make a new
component called-- buh, buh,
buh--
I want to display the user
data in a card component.
I'm using react.
What's it called?
React paper.
Brain is blinking on
this right now, OK?
And I'm going to just so I
can get the imports right.
Maybe it can get the
imports ready for me
on the first try this way.
Called.
There we go.
We're going to make the
new component in this file.
And now it knows I'm
using expo router too.
Let's see what we got.
And if you have your IDE plugged
in or your text prompt plugged
into your IDE or your
VS Code or whatever,
then it'll have a
lot more context
to work with while it's
generating your code.
But if not, it's good to keep
in mind what kinds of data
this is going to need.
So let's look here.
App/display user data.jsx.
Good.
They've got a
card, which-- yeah,
they imported card from
react native paper for UI.
And simple enough.
Let's copy this and let's see
where is it getting this data.
Use selector.
Good.
We'll go ahead and import
that or paste that and delete
that comment.
We know what this
file is called.
So what we've got here is use
selector from react redux.
And if you've noticed, this
guy is called use selector.
So this is another
hook from react redux.
So we're calling
use selector passing
it state or we're actually
what we're giving use selector.
Use selector is being
called right here.
We're passing it a inline
anonymous arrow function.
We're passing it a
function, which is
accessing state.user.formdata.
So let's break
that down a little
bit so that we can understand
what's going on here.
As we've talked about
before in class,
we can declare functions two
different ways in JavaScript.
We can declare with the
function keyword like this.
Like this component
has been written.
You can also declare it
with a const like this.
There we go.
And then give it whatever
arguments you want.
And then use this
fat arrow syntax.
So the equal sign bracket
there is the fat arrow syntax
that makes this whole
thing a arrow function.
And if your function
is only one line long
and it returns
something right away,
you can also shorthand
a function in JavaScript
and omit the curly brackets.
Just for short.
This is the same as this.
There we go.
We're returning
state.user.formdata.
But yeah, if all you're doing
is you have a one line function
and it returns
something right away,
you don't need the
return keyword.
And if it's one line, you
also don't need brackets.
And if you don't need to call
this function anywhere else
and you only need to use it
once right where you're at,
you also don't need
to give it a name.
You can just write the
function inline without a name.
That's why it's
called anonymous.
It has no name.
We know it's a function
because we have this fat arrow
syntax here.
No brackets because
it's one line.
No return statement because
this state.user.formdata
is being returned right away.
So funny syntax, but
thought I'd break that
down so that we can read it and
understand what's going on here.
And so we're getting
state.user.formdata
Now how do we know what
we need to do with state.
Let's look again at our slice.
So at our slice, we have
made a slice in our state.
A slice is just a
piece of our state.
And we've called this one user.
And inside of user, we have
something called form data.
So in here, we're
state.user.formdata.
And that is how we
grab this object
or whatever the object has been
updated to be at that point.
And then let's look here.
I think that's about it.
So we've got that.
We've got a view
that wraps our card.
Our card has a
title and content.
Don't worry too much about like
why does this have a dot title
and dot content.
This is just the card
syntax for setting up
a card if you want more details
on why that's written that way.
Just go to React Native
paper documentation online
and check that.
Then let's see what
that looks like.
So let's go to our index.jsx.
And we're going to need
a way to navigate there.
So if you remember
before, we had a button
to go to the
registration screen.
Let's just make another one.
We made a super simple
function there just
to name it so we
could read it well.
Instead of that, I'm going
to do something funny here,
like we saw before.
I'm going to make a
inline anonymous function.
And we're going to call
router.push and dot slash
or is it slash?
And it doesn't seem to have--
or at least my IDEs autocomplete
doesn't seem to have this file.
Just to make sure
I don't typo this
because it is case sensitive
and the name matters,
paste that right there.
Yeah, and it's the same.
We do router.push.
Need at the end, apparently.
Syntax is for droids.
I've got a new button
that we can navigate there
with And then do we have our
metro bundler running still?
Looks like we do.
And it was throwing errors
as I was writing that stuff.
So if we go to oh, we didn't
update the name of that button.
Let's see.
View user data.
Unmatched root.
Why is that?
I think the router should be
hot refreshable, but maybe
just in case we need to
restart our metro bundler
when we add a new route.
I don't think we do.
I guess we do.
So here we've got user data.
No user data available.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
We've got some smart
rendering here.
So let's see.
We've got userdata.firstname.
So we're just saying, hey,
let's use this selector
to get whatever user
data we have in state.
And if we do userdata.firstname
in other words
like if there's a first
name object in here
or first name key with
a value, then we'll
render everything inside these
parentheses from here to here.
Or we'll render this.
So since userdata.firstname
doesn't exist,
we're rendering this
bit down at the bottom,
which is some smart rendering.
Let's go back.
Let's do some test user
with a fake phone number.
Submit that and then
view our user data.
Oh, look at that.
Now we've got user data
with all of the info
that we added before.
And if we check our logs,
actually it probably
won't be in the logs.
Oh, it is in the logs.
We can see that when we
dispatched the action to add
to our store, that data got
logged as the store action was
being resolved there.
So we're able to resolve this
data in a different page,
different component
on a different page,
and still access the same data
that we had back in our home
page, our index page.
So that is the basics of
how you set up your redux
store using your store.js.
Don't forget the provider
wrapping your entire app
starting at your
layout.jsx file.
Then you just need
to set up a slice.
This is a super basic slice.
It's less than 20 lines and
new line characters and all.
When we set up our slices to
communicate with our Django
store, this file will
get a bit bigger.
It will also handle not only
updating our state data here
in our front end
store, but we will also
put in data to handle
network requests
or get and post request
actions to our back end.
And it will track those
asynchronously here
in our slice.
So this works really well for
just a super quick boilerplate
state management for our app.
And then when we
get to the point
where we want to
add extra reducers,
it also helps our network
request resolve asynchronously
pretty easily, as well.
If there are any questions,
go ahead and message me
in Teams or in Canvas.
Thanks.